GBBO.S08E08.Forgotten.Bakes.Week.srt
Hey, Sandi, look, I've been baking.
I'm not sure I've totally nailed it.
I put them in the oven and forgot
about them.  That's brilliant!  Is it?
Yeah, it's the theme of the week,
Forgotten Bakes.
Sometimes it's like I'm working
on a psychic level.
Yeah, that's certainly one
explanation.
I've got to go, I've left the bath
running.
Welcome to
The Great British Bake-Off.
NARRATOR: Last time...  One more
toss and then I'm done.
..there was an Italian heat wave...
Ah!
..Sophie and Liam impressed
with their creativity...
It's just amazing to look at.
..but Steven had the style AND
substance...
I think you could sell them in any
pastry shop in Italy.
..landing his third Star Baker
title.
Stacey and Kate were stretched out
of shape...
Absolute disaster.
..but it was Yan who unravelled...
Oh, no lamination.  ..and we had
to say arrivederci.
A totally wonderful adventure.
Thank you so much.
SANDI: This time...
Don't leak. Don't leak, don't leak.
..it's a blast from the past
with Forgotten Bakes...
Who has ever have heard of this
before?
A sweet and savoury signature...
I've literally dropped a clanger!
..a traditional technical tart...
It's raw.  ..and a grand
Victorian show stopper...
Don't drop it...  That demands...
the utmost finesse.
The quarterfinals are here.
The competition is on now.
It's quite intense.
Final five!
It's very exciting.
I can't actually believe
I'm still here. It's great.
It's a bit weird, you're like,
"Oh, my God, where is everyone?"
It feels different now, it's going
to be a lot harder.
We know what's riding on how we
perform on each bake, and yeah,
I think everyone's feeling it now.
Over the next few days, I just need
to be consistent.
Just bang out three good bakes,
and I should be fine.
Let's see what happens, innit?
Morning, bakers.  This week is all
about Forgotten Bakes.
It's those classic creations of the
past, which lately may have been,
I don't know, overlooked.
For your Signature Challenge,
Prue and Paul would love you to
make a Bedfordshire clanger.
It's a bit like a Cornish pasty,
except this was for a farm worker's
lunch as opposed to a tin miner's
lunch.  Made from suet pastry, your
clanger should be sweet at one end,
savoury at the other, with a sneaky
pastry wall dividing the two,
assembled by a tiny pastry builder
called Neville.
You worry me. The judges would like
your 2017 take on this traditional
recipe. Any flavours that you like,
you've got two hours to make
four Bedfordshire clangers.
On your marks.  Get set.  Bake.
Clanger's a weird name.
The clanger.
This is not the kind of baking
I like to do.
No, I'm not really into making
clangers, no.
Conceptually, I think it works
really well.
You know, the savoury and the sweet,
your entire meal in one.
I suppose it's a bit like
aeroplane food.
Just got to deliver on this,
haven't I? Not drop any clangers.
I'm here all week!
PRUE:  The clanger is a bit like
a Cornish pasty,
except it's long and thin
and sausage-shaped because it has
to contain two fillings.
One of the dangers is getting
the fillings right
so that they're not too wet
and will leak out.
The other danger is trying to
overcompensate for that,
and so they'll make their fillings
too dry.
You don't want a stodgy clanger.
And the key thing about the clanger
is the pastry itself.
It must be made with suet.
If the pastry's too flimsy and it
breaks apart,
it indicates you haven't worked
the dough enough.
Over-mix, it'll be like rubber
and you'll break your teeth
getting into it.
It's finding that balance
between the two.
Just rubbing in my butter
into my suet,
which is that disgusting-looking
thing there that's like baked, like,
worms or something, isn't it?
NOEL:  Suet is a fat found around the
loins and kidneys of cows and sheep.
That yummy fat!
When used to make pastry,
it creates a soft texture,
firm enough to hold its shape
when filled.
It's replacing butter or lard or
whatever you decide to use.
I think they originally used it
because it's so much cheaper
than butter.
It's quite similar to other
pastries, try not to overwork it.
Hello, Steven.  Good morning.
So, Bedfordshire clanger...
We're going Mediterranean.
Lots of herbs and spices.
Steven's spicy clangers will be
filled with feta and onion
at one end,
and orange blossom baklava
at the other.
What sort of colour are you going to
get on your pastry?
This colour, this colour,
or this colour?
Yeah, there you go.  I think
a bit more Prue!
Prue!
We are preparing a station for
rolling.
Can I sprinkle some?  Yeah.
Do you want me to show you how to
do it like a baker? Go on, then.
See, you get a pinch,
then you just do this.
Obviously, I wasn't going to soil
my hands!
Good morning, Liam.
Hi, Liam. So I want to know about
your pastry.
I want the pastry to be relatively
short, like flaky,
sort of melt-in-the-mouth situation.
But I want it to be robust enough
to keep the fillings in.
Liam's pastry will melt away
to reveal flavours inspired by
his favourite pizza toppings -
a pesto chicken and mozzarella
savoury filling will sit
alongside an apple and plum sweet.
Because it's like pizza-inspired,
I'm doing some dipping sauces
as well.
Who has dipping sauces with a pizza?
I do.  What?  What?  You have dipping
sauces with pizza!
NOEL:  Yeah, you do. Yeah.
Oh, this youth of today!
I know.
This is a modern take, so let's see
what it's like.
Traditionally, Bedfordshire clangers
had a meat, potato,
and diced veg filling at one end,
with apple and jam at the other.
It's vital the bakers make an
equally brilliant sweet and savoury
marriage.  It's a really cool
concept.
Like, it's just a pasty with a sweet
and savoury side.
It's nothing, like, that
ground-breaking,
no disrespect, but...
The people of Bedfordshire
will be up in arms!
The main bit of cooking is the
caramelized onions,
so I've got to get that on ASAP.
I'm going for Camembert, rocket,
pine nuts and caramelised onions.
It's kind of a posh take on a
cheese and pickle.
Stacey's the only baker using a wet
filling in her clangers.
A cinnamon custard will surround the
fresh blueberries
and apple of her sweet.
How are you containing that
little river of custard?
Well, this particular custard's
quite thick.
When it's inside, do you think it
will loosen up?
I've had a bit of a leaky clanger
issue over the week.
It's been quite stressful,
I've got to tell you.
When it's in, I'm walking away from
the oven. I don't what to see
what's going on in there!
OK, well, good luck, Stacey.
Thank you very much. See you later.
Sounds delicious.
I hope so.
Whilst most of the bakers are
sticking to familiar flavours,
some are taking inspiration
from further afield.
This is the char siu,
I love this marinade.
It's got all yummy sauces.
It's got hoi sin, soy sauce,
rice wine vinegar, loads of
those cool stuff.
Sophie's char siu marinade will
flavour the pork loin
in a savoury filling, which will be
complemented by a banana and pecan
praline sweet.
Interesting that you've chosen
char siu.
Have you practised this?
A couple of times, yeah.
Confident?  Yeaaaah.
You do know it's semifinal week
next week?  I know, I know!
You know, I'm just taking every week
as it comes because I don't want to
be disappointed. Hope for the best,
expect the worst.
Good luck, Sophie.  Thank you very
much.
Thank you.  Thank you.
Good luck, Sophie.
Sophie isn't the only baker giving
her clanger an exotic twist.
I really enjoy Mexican food, so it's
going to be a Mexican bean burrito.
The Bedfordshire clanger's
gone on holiday!
Kate's burrito-inspired clanger will
marry her vegetable chilli savoury
filling with a Caribbean banana
rice pudding sweet.
I think Sophie's using banana.
Either apple or banana works well.
You don't get too much fluid
coming off it.
So yeah, it doesn't surprise me
if there's lots of banana and apple
doing the rounds.
I haven't had a problem with
the clangers leaking in the oven,
but my baklava is quite dry.
There's no fresh fruit in there
to burst,
so maybe it was the right thing
to do.
Bakers, you are halfway through
your Signature Challenge!
Halfway!  So as Oasis would say,
don't look back in clanger.
That was terrible.
He's getting funnier every week.
Have you noticed?
With multiple clangers to be filled,
assembled and sealed,
time management in the final hour
is crucial.
I think we're ready for action.
It's pastry time.
This is my pastry,
which has been rested.
Now, I'm going to start assembling.
Fill it, roll it over, egg wash.
The big thing is no leaking.
I measured it, but it's not precise.
I just measured it so I looked like
I know what I'm doing!
You know? All the gear, no idea.
Originally, Bedfordshire clangers
comprised one-third sweet
to two-thirds savoury.
Steven is the only baker sticking
rigidly to this tradition.
Sweet will sit here and savoury
will sit here.
That's so sweet, your little Berlin
wall that you've done in the middle.
I was going to say Trump wall,
but I don't...  Trump wall?  Oh, you
can say it.  Solar-panelled.
It stops the sweet and the savoury
melanging in the middle.
God forbid you would have a sweet
and savoury melange.
I'm in a bit of a rush.
I need to concentrate on my custard.
Have you started them?
Yeah, yeah. I've got two done
already.
They in the oven?  No, no, no.
I'm scoring it, just like you would
for bread, cos there is
some expansion.
I'm just doing the slashes.
Traditionally, slashes were placed
on either end of the clangers to
differentiate between sweet
and savoury.
I've got my little pig, that's my
pork, and I've got my banana.
You don't want to be tucking into
your sweet end
when you want your savoury.
That's my sweet.
I haven't got time,
oh, my God, oh, my God!
Right, bakers, half an hour!
Half an hour!
I haven't spent enough time checking
they're not going to be leaky.
You're not gonna leak, you're not
gonna leak, you're not gonna leak.
You'll behave yourself.
Going in, can't wait.
They take about 25 minutes,
which is...exactly what I have.
I think one of them's going to leak.
I'm really, really rushing.
They're probably going to get a bit
less than they should.
Little bit late, I might say.
Don't leak. Don't leak, don't leak.
Do not leak. Let's just do 15
minutes and see what happens.
Oh!  Are you all right?
Let's eat Camembert.  Oh, cheese!
Bakers...
IMITATES A CLANGER
What are you doing?
I'm being a clanger.
You've got 15 minutes,
15 minutes!
Ooh-oooh!
I can't look.
Oh, oh, there's a bit of browning,
there's a bit of browning.
Do you know what? If they do leak,
but they look all right and they
taste all right, then it'll be OK.
One is definitely going to leak.
No leakage so far, so...
They need longer than
we've got left.
They're leaking.
They've cracked a bit more
than I'd want.
They smell nice, though.
Mine are massive,
I've got a huge clanger.
The cheese. I'm very upset
about that.
I'm just making my dipping sauces.
It's not cooking, at all.
What temperature are you doing yours
at?  240.  240!  I'm just hammering it.
Put it on 240?  Yeah, yeah, yeah, go.
OK, thank you.  Bakers, you have five
minutes left, just five minutes!
We've got five minutes!
Oh, my God, they're not going
to be done.
Oh, my God, two are leaking!
Oh, three are leaking!
They're all bloody leaking!
Oh, dear. We have significant
leakage on all of them.
I think we're going to take it down
to the last minute.
One more minute on high.
My main worry is I'm not going to be
able to save them.
Highly embarrassed.
What a disaster.  Bakers, you have
one minute, one minute left!
Right, out they come.
They are not pretty.
Massive, aren't they?
They would have been a lot better if
they hadn't cracked open.
Where's my sauce pots?
Oh, my God!
Oh!
This is hot syrup, this is how
baklava is made.
They're really not done.
Oh, my God, what's just happened!
I've literally dropped a clanger!
Oh, my God, that's actually the
worst thing that could've happened.
Bakers, that is the end of your
Signature Challenge!
Please place your clangers
at the end of your stations.
Kate, pick yours up off the floor!
Oh, my God!
Disaster.
Oh, Kate.
The bakers' clangers must now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue.
This one ends up on the floor,
and they could have done with
longer in the oven as well.
I ran out of time at the end.
They do look a bit of a mess.
Never mind. Maybe it'll all be
redeemed because they will be so
delicious.
But how is he meant to tell which
end he is eating?
Well, it was going to have
decoration on, but again...
You ran out of time.
The pastry is quite tough.
But that's because it's not cooked.
You needed more seasoning in there.
You get a texture of rice and that's
pretty much what you get.
What a shame. Right...
The sweet.
I really like that, the rice
pudding.
It's not too claggy.
It's properly good.  I think nearly
all your problems come down
to under-baking.
The pastry is just not right.
Thank you.  OK.
When you look at the uniformity,
it's there.
Great colour, the cuts are distinct.
I think you've done a great job.
They look very, very good.
Thank you.  Wow, that's delicate to
pick up, that.
SANDI: Oh, lovely.
You're so mean!
So mean!
You are so good at flavour.
Lovely pesto - bang!
And that pastry is so, so delicate.
You can barely pick it up.
Just perhaps not quite robust enough
for a clanger.
Are you going to try the dip?
Do you know, it's perfectly all
right, but Mediterranean flavours
are so strong, you really don't
need it.
No, I agree. Right, the sweet.
The flavours are very, very good.
I think the balance of the fruit
is excellent.
The pastry is so light, though.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh.  Next time, work that
pastry a little bit more.
OK?  Cool.  Thank you.
Lovely colour. I like the
decoration.
I love the pig.
Love, love, love the pig.
Have you scored this?
Yes.  It's weakened it slightly
there.
Yup.  But it's robust.
All right.
The pastry's a little bit too thick.
I think it's baked well. It's
spongy, which is what it should be.
I just think it's a little bit too
thick.
I'm a bit disappointed in the
filling
because it's sort of predominantly
soy flavour.
I'm not getting much else.
Right.
Lovely flavour. Bit dry.
OK.
With the fact that your pastry's
still thick, that doesn't help.
Yeah.  Which is a bit of a shame.
You've been desperate to get rid of
those, haven't you?
Do you not have these in your
bakery?
Nope.  Clearly not!
It's not very robust there, if
you're carrying that into a field.
It's very good. And I think it's the
right texture.
It's moist without being sloppy.
Mm. Beautiful flavour.
I love the spices, the blends, and
it's a proper monstrous meal,
it's gorgeous. Now, looking at the
pudding, this is the baklava.
Hm.  I think that's absolutely
delicious.
I just think it's totally the
wrong shape. It's almost collapsed.
But the texture of the pastry is
very good.
Thank you, Steven.  Thank you very
much.  Delicious.  Thank you.
There's been a little
blueberry explosion.
So we know which end is sweet, even
if you hadn't put sweeties on.
Go in here.
I think you've got a great texture
there.
The pastry is nice and flaky.
It's a little bit soft,
as I'd expect from a suet crust.
That's lovely, that. The pastry's
flaky, it's light,
it's got lots of flavour.
It's got a nice crisp on the
outside.
And it's baked all the way through.
The caramelised onions are the
heroes in there.
Beautiful flavours.
The sweet...
I'm amazed that you got such good
texture,
because the blueberries were raw
and I rather expected them to sog up
the bottom of the pastry,
but they haven't.
That, young lady, is absolutely
delicious, that side.
SANDI: Yes!
Great clanger.  Feel good?
Feel great.
Thank you very much, guys.  Go, girl.
Thank you.
What a result. I don't know what
happened in there
but it's not what happens
when I'm at home.
I don't think it ever tasted that
good before.
Pretty good result, you know.
OK, it didn't look like a clanger.
Well, what does a clanger look like
anyway?
It's a little pink mouse
as far as I'm concerned.
When Prue said I was really good
at flavours, I was like, "Yeah."
But there's always, like, one
thing that I sort of fall short on.
But then that's good for me,
because there's always something to
improve on.
You know what, you've got to
keep laughing.
If you don't laugh, you'll cry.
It's not the end of the world.
I dropped a clanger but, you know,
we move on from it, don't we?
A little bit disappointing. Had this
been a couple of weeks ago
I would have considered that to be
an OK judging,
but now that puts me in a really
sort of bad position.
THUNDERCLAP
SANDI: There are now just two
challenges to go before
Paul and Prue decide which
baker's heading home
and which four will make the
semifinal.
Right, bakers, it is time to test
you on a classic technique
of the past,
set for you today by Paul.
Any advice, Paul?
This is all about precision.
I think he's finished.  OK, judges,
I'm going to have to ask you
to leave the tent.
Off you pop. OK.
Bakers, for your Technical Challenge
today,
Paul would love you to make
a traditional recipe
from Cumberland, the rum Nicky.
A large sweet tart,
this forgotten beauty has a sweet
shortcrust pastry base,
a rum-soaked fruity filling,
a rather tricky little
lattice number on top.
Paul would like you to serve it the
classic way with rum butter,
and you have an hour and a half.
On your marks...  Get set...
BOTH:  Bake!
I don't understand.
As usual, there is very little
detail.
I have literally got no idea what
I'm doing, to be honest.
Cumberland rum Nicky. Who has
ever heard of this before?
Not me. It is forgotten, and
probably for a good reason.
They're looking for a really
good rum Nicky.
And I don't know what that is!
So, Paul, why have you chosen
this - rum Nicky?
I came across this particular tart
about three years ago.
It's delicious.
Well, if you look at the inside of
that now,
it's all about joining the fruit
together
to create this one mass.
You have the flavour of the rum,
you have the fruit,
which almost melts in the mouth.
The pastry's flaky.
It's lovely. And you can really
taste the rum.
The rum is king in this.
We're looking for something that's
going to taste of rum but not of
alcohol.
Now, the lattice, it's going to be
fascinating to see
how they lattice.
If they totally enclose that pie,
the alcohol cannot evaporate off.
Now, to make it as it would have
been done 230 years ago,
I expect them to take this pastry
right into the edge.
OK. How long do they bake it for?
Because I know you didn't tell them
that.
35 minutes in total.
That will create a beautiful
golden pie.
And have you given them a machine
to make the rum butter with?
I'm not a monster, Prue.
I've supplied them with a wooden
spoon and a bowl.
So, I'm just chopping up this dried
fruit. The instruction is,
"Mix the dried fruits, ginger, rum
and sugar together
"and then leave to soak."
Pretty much it's just a standard
tart but it's just the filling
that's a bit odd.
To be honest with you, this kind of
soaked-fruit rum thing
is not my bag.
But I'll just, you know, wing it.
"Measure 50ml," and they haven't
provided a measuring jug. OK.
Anything even remotely useful on
the measuring front?
No.
Think about this, Steven. 50ml.
To be fair, I like rum-soaked
stuff, I love rum.
A little bit more for luck.
Mm. It smells like Christmas,
doesn't it?
No more rum. Whoo!
I'm going in.
Great, so...leave that to soak and
make the sweet shortcrust.
Let's get this done.
The recipe is really quite detailed.
So, my instructions for making
the shortcrust pastry are
"make the shortcrust pastry".
It doesn't say how to do it,
but I'm going to combine my butter
and my sugar and my flour together
with fingertips.
You need to be careful
with shortcrust
that you don't overwork it, so,
like, nice, light, rubbing action.
I know this is a Forgotten Bake,
but fundamentally it's a fruit tart
with a lattice.
It's an alcoholic fruit tart with a
lattice top.
What's not to like?  Sounds like a
perfect drag queen if you ask me.
I've just added a teaspoon of lemon
juice and then one to two teaspoons
of cold water. It should be just
enough moisture just to combine it.
Do you know what? In all honesty,
the pastry that I made in the
Signature, that's what I want now.
Right, let's get this tin lined.
I don't know if I'm doing the whole
thing.
SHE MAKES POPPING SOUND
I'm just going to have to cut it and
hope for the best.
Could you... Yes.
Further, further, further.
Wow, you're quite bossy!
Just using a bit of pastry to get
into all the nooks.
Add the filling to the lined tin.
All the filling.
Then you add butter -
that's quite curious.
Bakers, you have 45 minutes to
finish your rum Nicky,
or, if you want to be a
bit more formal, your rum Nicholas.
If you have enough rum, you probably
do end up KNICKERLESS!
"14-strip lattice
with the remaining pastry."
Hm, hm, hm, hm.
I want 14 strips.
I'm just going to have to go with my
gut instincts on this one.
This is definitely the hardest part
of the challenge for me,
without a shadow of a doubt.
I just do not know how the hell
I'm going to do that.
I'm very, very bad at maths.
SHE SIGHS
So, as per the instructions, you
arrange it on a piece
of grease-proof paper first.
The trick is to sort of lay the
strip across
and then fold back the other ones
that you didn't do last time.
I think Steven is doing his
entirely different to mine.
He's doing some kind of pull-apart
one,
but I'm doing what I would call
a traditional lattice.
Yeah, I did think about doing it
that way but I like this way.
We're going to run cuts up the side
of the pastry
and as you pull the pastry apart,
you get lattice.
There's got to be a quicker way to
do this. I don't know!
What's happening here?
You know what, I don't know.
Intricate lattice work.
Yeah, but, you know what,
I've just turned round and Steven
is doing something
entirely different.
Is that good or bad?
It's obviously bad, isn't it?
Because he knows what he's doing
and I don't.  Maybe not.
Maybe you know what you're doing.
Come on now.  No.
Come on now.
I just want to get this lattice
right. It's really important,
really important. Have I got 14?
I don't know.
Bakers, you only have half an hour
left to whip up your rum Nicky.
30 minutes! My God!
SHE MURMURS
Over, under, over.
I'm taking ages, man.
Any idea? Argh!
I think I've messed this up.
I hate this so much.
Hate it.
That should just be enough
lattice work.
Too short.
This is where it's going to get a
bit messy.
What on earth was that?
This hasn't actually worked.
Right, we have got 20 minutes,
if that, to reroll this.
Steven, I can't help noticing that
you're doing the lattice work again.
Yeah, it didn't work out,
so I'm going to have to go back
to the drawing board.
You're all right, you've got time.
I don't know how long this thing
bakes for, but, hey-ho,
we'll just have to do our best.
I'm not really sure about this.
I'm thinking I should cut the rest
of it off.
I'm so bad at this.
God, it's not easy, is it?
I'm putting on an eggwash now, and
then that is going into the oven.
Everyone else is doing the whole
dish,
and I'm the only one that's done
the inner part of it.
SHE LAUGHS
Oh, gosh, I don't know.
So ragged.
I don't know what to do.
Right, it's going in.
Not the prettiest, which is
annoying.
Just whack the temperature up and
leave it.
I've whacked the temperature
right up because it's not going
to bake in time.
Do I trim it?
NOEL:  What is your gut telling you?
I don't know, I don't know,
I don't know.
You just have to trust your
instincts.
So bad.
You're all right, don't panic.
HE SIGHS
Let's hope we can redeem ourselves
with some rum butter.
So it says just make the rum butter,
and then it's just got the
ingredients.
Atrocious.
I'm just going to do 160 until
the end.
I don't think it's going to be in
the oven long enough.
I just took way too long
on the lattice.
Bakers, you have ten minutes,
just ten minutes to complete
your Technical Challenge.
It seems like an awful lot of sugar.
Who the hell would want to have this
to eat?
I remember it being quite grainy,
so I'm not expecting it
to be mega smooth.
KATE:  My God, I am absolutely
sweating.
It's just not butter. That can't be
right. It tastes disgusting.
I think maybe I'll just keep
stirring it until the end
and hopefully it gets less grainy.
I started this in 1792
and I'm still going!
Bakers, you've got just one minute
left, one minute.
God, they do not make your life
easy.
KATE:  It's come together now.
It's nice and whippy.
Rum butter's done.
I think we're doing all right.
I'm never doing this again.
This is enough rum butter.
30 seconds!
Stunning.
It's raw. Atrocious.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your rum Nickys
up to the gingham table.
Raw, raw, raw.
NOEL:  Paul and Prue are looking
for a thin pastry bottom,
a beautiful lattice top
and a smooth rum butter.
And as usual, they won't know
whose rum Nicky is whose.
PAUL:  Right, we'll start with the
one at the end.
You needed to take the sides up
to the top of the plate.
That's a major issue.
The lattice is certainly not cooked
and I'll eat my hat if the bottom
is cooked.
Wow...we have a raw base.
Yeah.
Pastry is very raw.  It is.
Right, well, that was a
disappointment.
Now, the lattice work on this
is even.
You need to allow gaps to allow
the alcohol to evaporate.
And again, I think it would be much
better
if the pastry came to the edge.
The rum flavour is there,
but the alcohol couldn't penetrate
through the sheer volume of lattice.
And a bit grainy on the rum butter
as well.
Now moving on to number three,
this is more like it.
A nice coverage of the pastry,
which goes right to the end.
The lattice is a bit sparse -
that's a little bit too thin.
But it has got the best colour,
it's nice and brown.
Mm. I could just sit there
and eat a lot of that.
It just looks a little bit
thrown together.
Right, moving onto this.
Lattice - very good.
Needed less of them. Right...
You can see how soft that pastry
is underneath.
It's much more cooked than
I thought it would be.
I mean, the flavours are lovely.
It looks neat.
Yes, it looks very nice.
I think if it'd had a little longer
in the oven,
it would be a pretty good pie.
Moving on to the last one, we have
something that's shrunk back
slightly from the sides, but the
colour is not bad on the edge.
They've so nearly got it to the end.
It's just a little bit again in the
middle, but it nearly done, yes.
Yeah, it's good. It's very nice
and thin, the pastry.
Less alcohol in that one as well.
You've got the flavour of the rum.
Very good.
Bit smoother on the butter as well.
This is perfect rum butter.
SANDI: Prue and Paul will now rank
the rum Nickys
from the worst to the best.
OK, in fifth place is this one.
Liam, obviously it needed to go
in the oven for longer
because it's quite raw.
In fourth place is this one.
Sophie, the lattice looks absolutely
beautiful, but it is too closed.
In third position is this one.
Too many lattice strips.
It said 14, so we did 14.
13, 14, 15.
Oh, 15. Oh!
I've always had a problem with
maths.
Right, in second place
is this one here.
Kate, this is absolutely delicious.
The rum butter is the best
we've seen.
So, in first place is this one.
Nice gaps between the lattice
and the balance of flavours in the
fruit and the rum is perfect.
Although your butter's a little
bit grainy.
That was unexpected.
I feel incredible. I do feel a
little bit like I cheated, though.
I just threw it in the oven
and it came first.
But I'll take it!
I hope it's redeemed me a little bit
from this morning.
Because if I'd done really bad,
I'd have to do something spectacular
tomorrow
to even be considered to stay.
To come third in the Technical is
great at this late stage.
So, tomorrow I'll have to get
my head down and go for it.
Every element needs to be pukka.
I don't think anyone says pukka
any more, but...pukka!
I'm really not happy. All in all,
probably the worst day
I've had actually so far.
So, not great to be putting
that sort of thing out in
the quarterfinals.
I hate coming last.
I'm just going to have to pull
it out of the bag again.
Yeah, I've got to do a vintage Liam.
NOEL:  One challenge left before
Paul and Prue choose Star Baker
and decide who must miss out
on a place in the semifinal.
SANDI: I don't know if
I can stand the tension.
Quarterfinals, you'd think you might
know who's going to get into the top
and it's all over the place.
I think Steven's
had a bit of a dip.
He's coming back now, strong, coming
into the semifinals next week.
This is the time to get good.
But Stacey, handshake
from her clanger.
The pastries, the shape, the
flavour - it ticked all the boxes.
I would absolutely love
Stacey to make it to Star Baker
cos she's worked so
hard to get there.
I think Liam, Sophie and Kate are
all in a little bit of trouble.
Kate didn't do too
well on the Signature.
But she came back cos
her Rum Nicky was second.
I'd like to see
Liam in the semifinal
BUT coming last in the Technical
automatically puts you
into a difficult position
and I think Sophie's in
quite a bit of trouble.
Who could believe this?
Her char siu pork was...
was OK, but she was
fourth in the Technical
and I think Sophie has the
capability of saving herself,
but it's down to the Showstopper.
If they want to get through
to the semifinal next week,
they've got to pull their socks up
and create something
that's pure magic.
Morning, bakers. For your
Showstopper Challenge today,
we're heading back
to Victorian times.
COCKNEY ACCENT:  So, I'm going
up a bleeding chimney...
AS QUEEN VICTORIA:  ..and
Sandi will not be amused.
Today, the judges would like you
to make a Victorian favourite -
the Savoy cake.
Now, I'm not going to lie to you,
traditionally, this banqueting
centrepiece was rather inedible,
but Prue and Paul
would like you to make
a light, delicate sponge,
baked in an elaborate mould,
with a hard sugar coating.
Your Savoy cake can be
any flavour you want
but, to create that Victorian drama,
it must be served on a plinth
also created from sponge.
So, you need a bit of
sponge engineering.
You need to be the Brunel of baking.
You have three-and-a-half hours.
NOEL AND SANDI: On your
marks, get set, bake.
STEVEN:  The last bake before
the semifinals is big anyway.
It doesn't make it any easier, the
fact this is a complete unknown,
this cake. I don't think one's
been seen since about 1890.
KATE:  I don't really think
this is like any other cake
I've, kind of, had before.
It's a bit of a weird
one, this, isn't it?
SOPHIE:  Not a great day yesterday.
I like to come back to cakes.
I don't like stodgy,
old-fashioned pastry.
I like pretty things!
PRUE:  A Victorian Savoy cake would
have been an amazing centrepiece,
a real Showstopper,
and that's what we
want from our bakers.
But it was very seldom eaten.
We want them to
taste amazing as well.
This is going to be
a little bit tricky.
Traditionally, the Savoy cake is
made in quite an elaborate mould
but there's no
rising agent in there,
there's no fat in there.
So, the blending of the whites
and the yolks is critical
because if they beat
that thing to death,
the whole thing will collapse.
This cake was produced, actually,
for the kings and
queens of the time.
Now, we're asking them to produce
exactly the same standard
but for the gingham altar.
This has to be absolutely exquisite.
SANDI: The Savoy cake rose to
prominence during the 19th century
and featured among the sweet
entremets of a Victorian dinner.
In order to achieve
its impressive height,
a number of intricate and
elaborate moulded cakes
were stacked up on
a base plinth cake.
The sponge texture was
light and delicate,
and flavoured with
lemon or orange zest.
Although sometimes
lightly decorated,
the naked sponge was the star -
featuring a smooth, thin
coating of hard baked sugar
which would preserve the cake
for weeks, or sometimes months.
At the moment, I am just
cracking an awful lot of eggs.
Absolutely at capacity.
Savoy cake batter is made by
carefully folding whisked egg whites
into an egg yolk and flour mixture.
You're just relying on
the power of the eggs.
I'm so desperate to rush
but, if I rush this,
it's just going to
knock all the air out and
it will just end up...
I don't want to know what
it will end up looking like.
Stacey, however, isn't holding back.
I've got a lot to do in a very,
very, very short space of time.
If I didn't give myself a lot to do,
then it wouldn't be me, would it?
NOEL:  Not only is Stacey doing
two different flavoured sponges,
she's loading her
heart-shaped Savoy cake
with macaroons, madeleines,
jellies and swirled meringues.
Why have you gone and
made it so complicated?
I'll tell you why.
Erm, because it's week eight,
and it's the Showstopper
of week eight,
and I just want to go all out.
I really think you
look well organised.
I think it's possible
you'll pull it off so...
Let's see.  ..let's see,
Stacey. Good luck.  Thank you.
Right, where am I?
"Add the zest of a lemon."
SANDI: Stacey, Liam and Sophie
are flavouring their cakes
the Victorian way,
with citrus zest.
I'm also going to put a little bit
of yuzu powder and yuzu juice.
The main flavours are
lemon and elderflower.
But not everyone is
sticking with tradition.
Chestnut puree, rum and orange
are the overarching flavours.
Our job here today is to take
what essentially is
a plain, boring,
tasteless, inedible cake
and make it light and delicious.
Easy!
Candied nuts and 16
handcrafted fondant flowers
will bedeck Steven's chestnut rum
cake filled with cinnamon apples.
The chestnut didn't make
the Savoy cake too heavy?
No, what the chestnut puree does
is just add a little
bit of structure to it
but it does add a little
bit of flavour as well.
Good luck with the
Savoy cake.  Thank you.
I hope I tick the flavour box today
because, you know, I'm not
going stupidly elaborate
with the design on this.
It's going to be classic,
simple and beautiful,
so I do want to make sure
that the flavours are there.
KATE:  I'm doing pecan and caramel.
I really, really love
the flavours of it
and I think it's a chance
to update the Savoy cake.
Good morning, Kate. How are you?
Morning. Good, thanks.
Tell us all about your Savoy cake.
I'm going to do, erm,
the Liver Building turret.
Brilliant. You're Star Baker!
Thank you very much indeed.
NOEL:  Chocolate decorations
will adorn Kate's
six-sponge Liverpool landmark,
topped with a silver
fondant liver bird.
I'm not using, like, a
traditional Bundt tin.
I'm going for an assembly
of many shapes and sizes.
How many eggs is it?
60.  60 eggs?  Yeah.
Wow.  This one was particularly
painful for the chicken.
It took a little bit
of the chicken with it.
You've practised this?  Yeah.
You can get it done in time?  Yeah.
It's semifinal week next week.
Go big or go home.
Exactly.
NOEL:  Whilst Liam won't be
impressing the judges with size,
he's hoping a little magic
will keep him from going home.
Savoy cake's all about
witchcraft and wizardry.
If I had a magic wand,
I would propel myself...
..to next week!
Liam's hoping to leave
the judges spellbound
with his three-tiered Savoy cake,
festooned with spun
sugar magic, a chocolate wand
and bottles of enchanting
bourbon caramel sauce.
Have you had problems with getting
the cakes out of the mould?
First time, yeah, I did.
You did?  First time I did
but you have to, like, absolutely
pack it with loads of icing sugar
so it doesn't, like, stay in there.
So, hopefully,
it does come out today.
I'm lining it with vegetable fat.
What I'm going to do then
is coat it with icing sugar.
The idea is that when it bakes,
you're going to get,
like, a crust of sugar.
Prue and Paul will be
looking for a sugar crust
that's thin, crisp
and perfectly smooth.
SOPHIE:  There's a little
bit missing there,
so I'm just making sure that
the whole thing is lined.
This is the most vital part.
Grease it up.
To give the Savoy cake
its intricate detail...
I'm going to zhoosh it around.
..the bakers must
make sure their batter
gets into every nook and cranny.
STEVEN:  I'm just gently
pouring this batter in.
This is a particularly
intricate tin.
I've had varying degrees of
success with this at home.
I just have to keep my
fingers crossed on this one.
SOPHIE:  I read that they
would cover them in parchment
so that the mixture would,
sort of, stay in the tin
and go right to the edges.
I like to be authentic.
NOEL:  The plinth in Sophie's
historically accurate cake
will be sandwiched
with yuzu buttercream,
circled by a croquembouche,
all topped with a
chocolate showpiece.
I'm doing a sort of
flower, essentially,
so I'm doing petals and then
gluing them around a little ball.
All out of chocolate?
All out of chocolate, yes.
Impressive. You've
obviously practised this.
HIGH-PITCHED:  Yeah!
That was quite a high "yeah".
"Yeah!" "Yeah!"
I have practised it.
It hasn't come out looking
as beautiful as I would like
but hopefully it'll
look good enough.
Right, this baby is going in.
Everything's going to
go in at the same time
because I've got a lot
of choux buns to do.
I'll need the oven as soon
as I can, basically.
STEVEN:  Oven door doesn't get
opened until at least an hour.
I'm not touching it because,
as soon as you open it
and let some of that heat out,
the risk is it will collapse.
Cakes in the oven...
Cake's in. Macaroons.
..the bakers can
focus on their trimmings.
That is choux pastry.
Or it will be.
All except for Kate, who's
got four more cakes to make.
This is batch number two.
I've got a lot to do in
comparison to everyone else
who's doing a
single-tier one or whatever.
I've just got to go for it anyway.
I'm going to flip this,
so you might want to stand back.
You don't want a hot
nut in your face, do you?
STACEY:  I'm making macaroons.
There's a lot to do, still,
but, so far, I'm fine.
This is the bourbon-spiced
caramel.
It's a case of
smashing this one today.
SOPHIE:  This is the green
apple creme diplomat
that's going to go
inside the choux buns.
Hey, Soph. Wow, you've got quite
a nice green going on there.
Yeah.  I think this is quite
a good Showstopper for you.
I hope, because I had a
terrible day yesterday.
Quite tricky, isn't it?
It's not your kitchen.
There's more space than
there is in my kitchen.
Do you not live in a tent?
I live in a tent identical to this.
Bakers, you have one
and a half hours left.
We want to see those Savoy cakes.
Check out that bad boy.
Cool. Done.
Pretty happy.  I think I'm
going to try and turn it out.
Shall we see what the
first one looks like?
I just hope it comes out!
If it doesn't, then we're done.
Game over, mate.
Sometimes it stays and sometimes
it doesn't, so we will see.
Dah-dah-dah!
Little bit left behind.
I can live with that.
What do you think?
This looks nice.
Not bad. I've got a bit
of hole-age. "Hole-age"?
But you know what?
Overall, I've got a sugar crust.
SOPHIE:  Look at that,
look at that. Beautiful.
That should be OK.
I mean, it's got the sugar crust,
but I would have liked it a
bit more even all around.
HE CACKLES
Now I feel really happy.
Right, OK. So, make
the second Savoy cake.
This is the plinth, so this is what
the Bundt cake is going to sit on.
LIAM:  It's just the same
mixture as I did before.
KATE:  Final batch. I'm
just adding the pecan nuts do it.
How many eggs are you through?
All of them.
I was doing mine with
a side of omelette!
It's all about getting the
consistency of the choux right
so it can be piped,
but it's not too thick.
I feel like I'm panning for gold.
KATE:  That's my plinth, there.
It's a huge cake tin.
LIAM:  I'll give it, like,
half an hour.
STACEY:  That's going to go there.
That's going to go there.
Get on with it.
STEVEN:  That's going to go
in for about 45 minutes
and, right now, we're going to get
some beautiful decorating done.
That's the choux pastry done and
then I've got to pipe it out,
and then as soon as my
Savoy cakes are out of the oven,
I can then put the choux buns in.
The plans for decoration,
cut out a liver bird.
The story behind them is, if the
liver birds ever leave Liverpool,
it'll be no more -
so hopefully I can get one
on the top of this cake
or my cake will be no more,
and I will be no more
in the Bake Off tent.
I'm just making my wands.
I piped some
chocolate into the straws
and I'm going to freeze them
and, once they're set,
I'm going to poke them out.
This is my favourite thing
to do, jelly making.
Get them in the fridge, done.
And then it's just buttercream,
madeleines, meringues.
I've got this!
OK, the other one's
going to come out.
These are sugar paste roses.
I did 150 of them for my
mum's 60th cake last year
and it took me two days.
But if I can just get them to
look like roses, I'll be happy.
Choux buns are going to go in.
Right, let's have a look
at this cake. Not far off.
I just broke the oven.
BLEEP.
Oven door's come off.
Now I'm panicking.
I'm taking it out.
Can she share mine at 150?
No, no, no. You carry on.
It's all right,
I'll just hold it like this.
It could do with maybe
a minute or two longer.
Hopefully it won't deflate.
What happened to Stacey?
Her oven broke.  Her oven broke?
Yeah.  Oh, my God.
Queen Victoria, Prince Albert.
You be Prince Albert.
FAUX GERMAN ACCENT:  Bakers,
you have one hour left
to finish your sponge plinths.
Wow, it's more like Angela Merkel.
Everything was going so well!
Perfect.
The only thing I'm not pleased about
is that my plinth is a lot
darker than these two.
STEVEN:  Not bad.
The plinth's stuck in the mould.
Just carry on and I'll see if I can
try and decorate my way around this.
Oops, I'm going to take it out.
Yeah, I think we're just about OK.
So, let me just try and regroup.
Is there any oven on that's spare?
This is going to be for
the chocolate decorations.
I'm going to make a chocolate clock.
I'm going to make little petals
and hopefully make
a chocolate flower.
I do like to do this kind of stuff.
STEVEN:  Shall we do another one?
15 minutes. I want to
check my macaroons.
I've had to use another oven
but luckily there is another
oven to use, so we're all right.
Let's get madeleine-ing, shall we?
Get them in
the fridge to chill.
Let's see if we can
get these babies in.
The main thing now,
get the meringues in.
I've got two minutes
to get them in the oven.
You think you've got
more time than you have.
All of a sudden, it...
I've got to fill all my choux buns
and then I've got to
assemble my chocolate flower.
There's still quite a lot to do.
LIAM:  This is certainly not
the time for shaky hands.
I've got to keep composed.
Oh, God! Oh, no!
I've killed the liver bird off.
I picked it up to move
it and it just went...
SHE MAKES CRACKING SOUND
SHE SIGHS
I seem to jinx myself
regularly, don't I?
It's a bit lopsided.
So, this is improvisation.
I'm just going to make
it chocolate instead.
Savoy-oy, bakers.
You have 30 minutes left.
30 minutes.
STACEY:  The meringues
are in the oven,
so there's not a lot I
can do about it now.
OK, so, spun sugar.
SOPHIE:  It's taking ages
but we're getting there.
Right, sir, have you
come for your shave?
What is this?  It's...
It's fat, so I...
Oh!
KATE:  This is really stressful.
LIAM:  It's the finishing touches.
It's really weird that
I've finished kind of early.
But you've done great for time.
It's not like you're rushing.
Yeah, it's a bit weird.
In all honesty,
I've actually never timed this.
OK. I won't tell anybody!
SOPHIE:  I've just got a few
that I've dipped in freeze-dried
strawberries and in pearl sugar.
Without realising it,
this is probably something that the
Victorians would have appreciated.
STACEY:  The macaroons are a bit
big but it doesn't matter.
Big's better than small.
I gather you've been
slightly unhinged today.
Not ideal.  That's a
Bake Off first, I think.
Oh!
The spun sugar, now it's
just gone and dissolved.
Yeah.
Oh, I keep dropping them.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Five minutes before you have
to present your Savoy cake.
SOPHIE:  This is going to get
done by the skin of my teeth.
Don't drop it.
STACEY:  No, they're not great.
They're just not ready.
They're not cooked.
I don't even know if I should
even put them on, to be honest.
LIAM:  Do you know if Paul and Prue
could see it before the sugar melts?
Please, please, please, please.
SOPHIE:  Cutting it fine!
KATE:  Oh, my God,
that's just cracked.
Bakers, that is it.
Your time is up.
Please place your Showstopper Savoy
cakes at the end of your station.
If I just did...ten more.
Sophie, stop!
Oh, I've stopped!  Almost.
There's, like, this much left!
SANDI: It's judgment time for the
Victorian centrepieces,
but these Savoy cakes will need to
taste as good as they look.
Wow, Stacey! It really has got about
20 elements to it, hasn't it?
I'm very impressed that you got
all the cakes out quite cleanly.
There's a nice shiny sugar crust,
but, you struggled with
the meringue.
Yeah, they weren't done in time.
But overall, I think it's very you,
it's very Stacey.
NOEL: The Victorian Stacey.
We've got the orange on the top,
is that right?
Yeah.
It's got a nice texture.
Great flavour.
Really nice flavour.
The texture's amazing.
And the orange comes through well.
This is your lemon one,
is that right?
Yeah.  Very good texture.
That's not as well-flavoured
as the other, is it?
It's there, it's not as potent as
the orange one.
So you've got madeleines, you've got
macarons, you've got some jelly.
The madeleines were little bit flat,
but you've got the raspberry right
in the middle of that, haven't you?
The raspberry's very nice,
but the macaron, because they've
been sandwiched with a curd,
they've got very soggy.
The macarons I don't
particularly like, I don't think
they're well baked.
Let me try a bit of hard jelly.
Very nice.
I think overall, you've just gone
slightly OTT on the decoration.
But your two cakes are good!
It's a massive work!
Probably a titch overambitious.
But I think it's a real achievement.
I think it looks
a little bit haphazard.
It's a bit topsy-turvy.
I like the decoration of
the sugar, that's fine,
but you can see what's
happened to it over time.
It will collapse.
Humidity gets to it, destroys it.
So it's elderflower?
Elderflower and lemon.
It's quite dense, almost like you've
over-mixed it, you know?
Yeah.  I think you did.  But I'm just,
not catching any flavours at all.
OK.  The most flavour you get from
this is if you happen to get
a bit of caramel.
It's a little disappointing.
It is a little bit. The top layer's
better than the bottom,
I think the bottom one is burnt.
Quarterfinal you want, consistency.
Yeah.  I think you've had a really
great idea, Liam.
Don't think you quite pulled it off.
Sophie, I think that is a perfect
shape of a Victorian Savoy cake.
It's nice and high,
it's spectacular to look at.
The chocolate top is magnificent.
It's very, very clever.
If you break through,
you've got your plinth down
at the bottom down there,
which is sandwiched as well.
You've given that a flavour.
It's well baked all the way through.
You got a nice sugar coating
on the top of it as well,
and I love the design.
You've celebrated the Savoy cake,
which I like.
Right, I am going to take
a slice out of this.
The texture of the cake
is quite chewy.  OK.
But it's very pleasant.
I love the flavour. I just think
when you mixed it,
you may have just turned it a couple
more times than you needed to.  OK.
You've lost that air,
but you're not far off it.
Remind me what's in there.
Green Apple, creme diplomat.
Mmm. I love that green apple!
Really good.
I love that whole cake, actually.
Thank you.
Very elegant, very simple,
very small.
It makes you question what have you
spent the last few hours making.
All the time's been spent
on the roses,
and they do look beautiful.
It's very elegant.
I must say the sugar coating
looks really good.
And I do think you've been
very clever,
because those walnuts there
perfectly fit the mould.
It's beautifully done!
Now right in the middle there,
you have...  The cinnamon apples.
Love a cinnamon apple.
Not what I expected!
Nope. But it is delicious.
The texture I think, is lovely.
It's actually very brave of you to
put to put the chestnuts in there.
Because chestnut in itself,
is quite a heavy thing.  Yeah.
But it actually hasn't affected
the texture too much.
It's still quite light. but for me,
if you're gonna put chestnut in it,
get the flavour to come out.
Because it hasn't.  OK.
But nevertheless,
very pretty design.  Thank you.
Kate, please bring up
your Savoy cake.
Do you want some help?  Yes, please.
Ready?  Yep.
Weirdest removal firm.
I can see what it is.
The top of the Liver Building.
But, it's a bit simplistic.
The bottom plinth has
had a few major issues.
Yeah, it didn't turn out properly.
These seemed to have caught again.
It's all a bit broken up.
I do think it's a bit rough and
ready but I like the fact
that she's got the height.  Yeah.
It's a bold piece.
The sugar coating on it's good.
But, look how yellow that is.
60 eggs have made that
very, very yellow.
It's a bit dry, actually.
I was wondering if it's a bit
over-cooked at that.
I think it could be.
That's the one with pecans in it.
That's a much better cake.
That's delicious!  It's moister too.
I'm biased anyway.
I love the Liver Building.
But, star of the show's
that third one down.
I just think all the others...
too dry.  OK.
Wow, what a week.  It's been a
tremendous week.
So, I know that Stacey has been
really scrapping
with the Star Baker. Is it possible?
I think it's certainly possible
because Stacey has done remarkably
well.
I just think she attempted slightly
too much.
Having said that, this was about the
Savoy cake and they tasted amazing.
However, I think Steven is the
favourite coming into today.
He did create something that
technically was very good.
The flowers, perfect. Leaves are
great. The cake is well-made.
But the chestnut didn't get the
flavour.
Well, let's focus on ones who are in
trouble.
Sophie, perhaps, has saved herself.
Oh, Sophie's definitely saved
herself.
Nobody who can make a cake like that
can possibly go home.
So, Liam and Kate are in a bit of
trouble.
When you look at Kate's, she's used
pretty basic moulds,
and it's quite rudimentary,
the decoration, as well.
And she dried out a couple of the
sponges,
but the pecan one was particularly
good.
Whereas the elderflower in Liam's
one, you didn't think came through.
I couldn't taste anything. And then
he put sugar work on something that
was going to stand for a long period
of time, and it collapsed.
But she didn't do as well in her
signature as Liam.
His clangers were very good.  It
seems we keep balancing up things.
It goes like that all the time.
Yeah, we have to break it down,
go through the check list again and
then decide.
There's something lovely, Paul,
about sitting here,
listening to you talk in front of
the liver bird.
It's amazing, eh?  There you go.
You just ate its head.
It was so pretty up until that
minute.
Congratulations, bakers, on
surviving Forgotten Bakes week.
Now, I've got the great job this
week of announcing Star Baker.
The person who's won Star Baker this
week made clangers
with their trademark twist,
and made a Savoy cake that had
fabulous texture and flavour.
The Star Baker this week is...
Stacey.
Thank you.
So that leaves me with...just the
worst job.
Well done to all of you for getting
through to the quarterfinals,
but I'm afraid the person going home
is...
..Liam.
It's cool.  I'm so sorry.  It's cool.
In all fairness, like, I can look
back...
probably tomorrow morning and
think...
Yeah. I smashed it.
Onwards and upwards now.
It's not the end of me, it's just
the beginning,
do you know what I mean? So I'm
coming from Paul Hollywood's job
in a couple of years' time!
Don't stop baking.
So sorry to lose Liam.
He's learned a lot.
From the beginning to now, he's a
different baker,
totally different baker.
He's done really well to reach the
quarterfinals.
He should feel very proud of
himself.
But he had a bad Showstopper,
and that's what it came down to.
So glad you did it.
You've been so close.
Thank you very much.
Stacey has wanted Star Baker so
badly.
The last few weeks, she's got closer
and closer.
And this week, bingo.
Well done, Stace.  Thank you.
Well done.  Thank you.
Coming into the semifinal now.
This is the time to get Star Baker.
And she started to nail it this
week.
Her Savoy cake tasted amazing.
Did not think I would end up in week
nine, no way.
Week nine!
I'd like to say that I'm going to
tone it down for next week,
but, actually, I'm not. At all.
Next time...  There's no calming down
today.
..it's the semifinal.
The pressure's on.
Four bakers...  Do you know what?
I'm going to do it the sexy way.
..three patisserie challenges.
Oh...  This is insane, look at this.
Who will crack under the pressure?
Come along, dear.
WHISPERS:  I've got no idea what I'm
doing.
Gold leaf makes everything look
better.
I've done it wrong, I've done it
wrong.
And who will make it to the final...
They look pretty, don't they?
..of The Great British Bake Off?
It's been the hardest decision that
I've been involved with
in eight years of the Bake Off.
Subtitles by Ericsson